for the first time more Americans
support rather than oppose the
impeachment of President Donald Trump
this is based on a poll conducted by the
admittedly left-leaning PPP which found
that 48% of Americans now support while
only 41% of Americans oppose the
impeachment of President Donald Trump
now yes you could say well the pollster
is liberally biased David it's worth
noting to us the key point is that
according to the same poll which has
been conducted for the last three months
Americans used to be divided on the
impeachment of Trump now in Americans
are plus seven on the impeachment of
Trump over the non impeachment of Trump
a plus seven margin for impeachment is
absolutely historic for reference when
Richard Nixon first hit more people
being in favor of impeachment than
against it was after the Saturday Night
Live Saturday night massacre I keep
calling it the Saturday Night Live
Massacre there's plenty of massacres of
the Trump administration happening on
SNL in after the Saturday night massacre
we had a plurality of Americans
supporting the impeachment of Richard
Nixon by a one-point margin 44 to 43
we're talking about a seven-point margin
now 48 to 41 and you'll recall that with
the Nixon scandal the resignation took
ten months after the Saturday night
massacre when we finally got to a
plurality supporting impeachment we're
already at plus seven on this pad it's
not just the polling - it's also the
Vegas odds which shows that people are
putting their money where their mouth is
yes if you look at predict wise it has
it as a 27% chance that Trump leaves
office by the end of the year now that
could be by deaths impeachment or
resigning under threat of impeachment or
what regardless that's remarkable even
more remarkable is that the data the 48
to 41 data in favor of impeachment is
was collected from May 12th to 14th so
that after Trump fired FBI director
James Comey but it's before Donald Trump
leaked classified information to Russian
diplomats in the Oval Office so the
portion of Americans that want Trump
impeached the next time this poll is
done and that leaked the Russian Oval
Office leaks are sort of considered in
people's responses
we could be above 50% of the country
supporting impeachment of Donald Trump
you know it's interesting I'm a
progressive I follow the news every day
and I don't think that we're at the
point yet where we can call for the
impeachment of Donald Trump I think the
only thing that could really do it would
be the Russian investigation bearing
some fruit and I think for that you need
a smoking gun well there's a couple
things you're right in the sense that we
may still need more which it sort of
feels like we're on the cusp of but we
don't know right but there's another
aspect of these numbers which is a lot
of people don't realize that impeaching
the president is not firing the
president right impeachment is a type of
indictment Donald Trump could be removed
from office if found guilty of the
impeachable offenses but just an
impeachment it's sort of saying it's an
accusation too many people are saying
they don't support impeachment because
they think if I say I want to impeach
I'm saying I want a fire Trump
supporting impeachment just means you
believe there's enough concern to start
this process of investigation and I
think if people fully understood that
you'd see way more than 48 percent said
yeah I'm in favor of that right so the
house and peaches and then the Senate
convicts and it's actually happened
twice in American history where a
president was impeached both Andrew
Johnson and Bill Clinton but in both
cases they were able to survive being
removed from office
that's right Bill Clinton was impeached
but you might remember he did not resign
and he was not removed from office also
from this poll just one other
interesting bit of data the poll also
asked people's opinion about the firing
of James Comey 37 percent said they
supported the firing of James Comey 48
percent said that they opposed the
firing of James Comey it would be
interesting if in the next poll in
addition to do you want to impeach or
not they asked some some kind of
question ascertaining people's view of
the Russian Oval Office leaks of
classified information meanwhile if you
want to separate yourself from this
left-leaning
poll from PPP we've got the Gallup daily
tracking poll which has been tracking
presidential approval daily for
something like 40 years in the exact
same way Donald Trump is again nearing
new lows we talked about a month ago
Donald Trump it was down to 37% maybe
36% low I don't remember exactly Trump
popped back up too low
forty's and he's now back down to 38
percent approval as of two days ago
March I'm sorry May 15 to 30 838
statistically could be the same as 36
because we've got a margin of error of
about three we are talking about a
president who is just persistently low
in terms of approval and eventually that
has to have an impact as well doesn't it
yeah but of course the Constitution
mandates that you have bribery treason
or other high crimes and misdemeanors
and certainly colluding with the
Russians to get them elected would
qualify I'm not so sure if obstruction
of justice which we've learned about in
the past week or so would also qualify I
think it would wouldn't it win but it's
it's specifically big you know
yeah Iran misdemeanors isn't defined
that's why there's this sort of argument
that it's just ripe for political
manipulation which is basically like
yeah high crimes and misdemeanors if
you've got a Republican Senate and a
Republican House and an upcoming midterm
election and a president whose approval
rating is staying in the upper 30s to
low 40s why would I would Congress move
to impeach if you have the potential of
losing your seat in the 2018 midterms
with a president whose approval rating
maybe drops into the low 30s or upper
20s then you might have the political
decision made for impeachment and I
actually genuinely there's many aspects
of government that I genuinely dislike
but I genuinely dislike that the
impeachment process itself is just
completely open to be a politically a
political manipulation based on the
winds the wings of polling at the time
yeah and now we have one Democratic
congressman who is actually calling for
the impeachment of Donald Trump on the
House floor Al Green that's right Al
Green from from Texas and maybe we'll
dig into that a little bit more tomorrow